bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de file echo dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de deux
évolutions technologiques vent pour une
application pour visiter autrement le
château de versailles et le boom des
vélos électriques
mais d'abord cette annonce du groupe
espagnol dia qui souhaiterait supprimer
ses magasins en france l' annonce aurait
été faite ce mercredi aux salariés lors
d'un comité central d'entreprise il
existe 8 165 magasins en france dont 17
dans le département des yvelines
comme à montigny le bretonneux elancourt
trappe ou encore saint cyr l'école le
groupe pourrait soit fermé
définitivement ses enseignes françaises
soit se séparer des 200 points de vente
les moins rentables
un conseil d'administration devrait être
organisé très prochainement pour définir
les nouvelles orientations
en attendant lé client rencontré ce
mercredi après midi à montigny le
bretonneux trouve l annonce dommageable
c'est pas cher déjà par rapport aux
autres et de +6 des magasins de
proximité on est pas on n'y pas besoin
d'aller loin en fait pour faire ses
courses moi ça me pose pas de problème
parce que c'est mon vélo que rien par
moment tout le monde aime bien les
produits de bonne qualité pas cher et
puis ben si ça ferme après d'or valait
tendance à aller ben
supermarché plutôt attrape moi mais
c'est plus cher
la réforme des rythmes scolaires
coûterait trop cher à mettre en place
certaines mairies ont fait leurs comptes
et cela ne passe pas à elancourt par
exemple la ville a estimé ce coût à près
d'un million d'euros à plaisir
l'addition ce chiffre très précisément à
741 millions euros par an alors que le
budget consacré à la vie scolaire
s'élève à plus de 2 millions d'euros
alors c'est trop pour la maire ump de la
commune qui a fait le choix de ne pas
appliquer la loi à la rentrée prochaine
en détails voilà à quoi correspondent
ces dépenses
741 1000 euros sans la ville de plaisir
avec une aide de l'état de 150000 euros
à peu près qui n'est pas forcément
reconductible ce qui veut dire pour nous
une prise de décision aux graves qui est
je veux dire qui met en péril
véritablement le budget at-il nous ça
nous demande 25 personnes
supplémentaires sur la ville à plein
temps va falloir des animateurs
supplémentaires vous avez des règles au
niveau des embauches et puis on a essayé
aussi de contacter nos associations qui
pour certaines étaient assez partant de
rentrer dans le processus et puis il ya
tout ce qui impacte le gardiennage je
dirais de gardiennage dans le bon sens
du terme le matin le soir ça change
énormément les cantines tout est modifié
le nettoyage des écoles quand vous
recommencez à rentrer dans les écoles à
d'autres auraient ça impacte et ça
implique beaucoup de choses d'une page
de social maintenant pour continuer avec
cette semaine la mobilisation france des
gardiens de prison qui réclament plus de
moyens humains 400 surveillants
supplémentaires seraient nécessaires en
ile de france exemple concret à la
maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy elle est
censée accueillir à 501 détenus ils
seraient aujourd'hui 835 en janvier
dernier les surveillants de bois d'arcy
avaient déjà manifesté pour souligner la
recrudescence des agressions graves des
mesures ont été prises par la direction
mais les insultes et les menaces
resterait le quotidien des surveillants
pénitentiaires
on écoute à ce sujet cédric torrès du
syndicat ufap unsa des propos recueillis
par en
aujourd'hui on a enfermé tout le monde
toutes les personnes qui rentrent pas
dans le moule sauf comme on notait les
présences et des cocottes minutes le
couvert commence à soulever vous avez
des incidents qui se sont passés à réau
à sequedin à lens ans condé-sur-sarthe
des prises d'otages à laon et fait tout
ça mais ça ça devient une via notre
quotidien aujourd'hui à la prison n'a
pas de sens parce que vous avez d'études
qui reste allongé dans l'île jusqu'à 11
heures du matin parce qu'ils sont
inoccupés on a ils veulent pas
participer aux activités il n'y a aucune
obligation d'aller autre mouvement
social cette semaine celui des
sages-femmes c'était lundi 5 mai à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
des sages-femmes un mouvement concentrer
sur toute la france y compris dans les
yvelines comme au sein de la maternité
de l'hôpital mignot au chesnay
l'occasion pour ces sages femmes de
rappeler qu'elles sont toujours
mobilisés pour réclamer la
reconnaissance de leur profession et on
va écouter l'une d'elles au micro
d'anthony riches
partis manifester les consultations
étaient fermées donc avait aucune femme
en consultation et au niveau de l'année
on était le même effectif mais moins
deux mandats maternité aujourd'hui vous
attendez quoi de mobilisation et de
réunions qui vont avoir lieu vous et ben
voilà être collectivement phase 5 de
premier recours les grilles indiciaires
qui nous annoncent sont pas forcément ça
laisse ça l'aurait souhaité voilà donc
il y en ait pas forcément reconnus non
plus par rapport à ça
après et bien voilà on dit ça fait six
mois qu'on essaye de tenir et c'est pas
forcément facile au quotidien non plus
or on dit c'est fou parce que certaines
certaines catégories professionnelles
son gré mais en quelques années en
quelques jours ils ont ce qu'ils veulent
et nous on est quand même un certain
nombre de sages-femmes sur le triple à
français tiens voilà on rame depuis six
mois et on n'a toujours pas ce qu'on va
donc faire que des civils
de cette mobilisation de lundi les sages
femmes se disent toujours être déçus il
n'y aura pas de modification de leur
statut elle regrette de ne pas accéder à
ni à l'autonomie ni à la reconnaissance
quant aux négociations salariales elles
sont en cours mais les sages femmes se
disent peu optimiste sur la question et
enfin concernant la possibilité pour
elle de suivre une future maman du début
à la fin de sa grossesse quand celle ci
est normal les réunions de travail vont
reprendre la mobilisation donc continuer
a défini co se poursuit cette fois avec
l'entretien
et d'autres invités sur le plateau de
file echo ce soir pour parler d'une
nouvelle application qui s'appelle api
versailles une application dédiée au
château de versailles mais pas que et
pour en parler d'eux cofondatrice l'eia
agostini bonsoir stéphanie j'ai un bon
soir mais l'islam avoir rejoint alors
l'application a été lancée en septembre
dernier je peux dire on peut dire que le
démarrage en tout cas est d'abord un peu
timide mais c'est normal vous allez nous
expliquer pourquoi parce que c'est
quelque chose d'assez précurseur il
n'existe qu'en france que cinquante et
une application dit muséal c'est le
terme qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'envi
justement de cette application c'est
fanny nous sommes partis en fait d'une
volonté de changement à côté des d'audio
guides traditionnels que l'on trouve
dans les musées qui sont plutôt
classiques
scolaire même on a voulu proposer une
alternative vraiment différente quelque
chose qui change unique en son genre et
donc à petit versailles est né comme ça
avec de l'humour des anecdotes quelque
chose qui est une visite inoubliable
lorsqu'un intéressant si peut-être de
rappeler c'est un peu le parcours de
chacune de vous deux parce que vous
n'étiez pas forcément dans
l'informatique je pense notamment à vous
stephen jen puisque vous travaillez pour
un groupe pour un groupe automobile tout
à fait voilà donc j'ai passé moins 10
ans de ma carrière chez renault avec de
belles de belles expériences et voilà il
ya une autre les gags hosni bouzid et
déjà des fruits et j'avoue j'ai un pied
d'eau donc oui j'ai travaillé dix ans
marketing de chez orange et donc j'ai eu
envie de mettre cette expérience
professionnelle riche au service de
quelque chose de plus personnel qui me
tenait à coeur alors avant de parler
notamment du financement de ce projet
parce que ça se finisse évidemment une
application comme celle ci on va voir
comment il ya effectivement un coup
assez importants et des retombées que
vous en attendez surtout je vous propose
de regarder ce sujet
stéphanie et les ja ont lancé la
première application à télécharger pour
voir le château de versailles autrement
happy versailles c'est son nom permet
une heure de commentaires et plus de 70
illustration d'abord vous allez pénétrer
dans l'enceinte du château vous aurez
une visite sur 22 salles les 22 salles
de toute façon que vous vous êtes
obligés de traverser puisque on s'amuse
à dire souvent c'est vraiment le
parcours ikea au château de versailles
on passe d'une pièce pour aller dans
l'autre comme au temps de louis xiv vous
vous retrouvez mise en situation l'idée
c'est vraiment d'accrocher sur chaque
salle avec des anecdotes des choses
insolites que l'on n'entend pas dans les
eaux de guise de traditionnel pour avoir
une visite vraiment décalé vous avez
terminé votre visite vous installer
tranquillement dans le jardin où vous
faites le tour du parc du château de
versailles et vous pouvez écouter des
anecdotes vraiment méconnu sur louis xiv
et son amour pour les signes louis xiv
qui avait sa carte sa carte préférée
dans un bassin où marie-antoinette la
kate moss 18e comment elle s'habillait
comment elle se préparait pour une
soirée tendance autre anecdote à retenir
à l'époque dix mille personnes venaient
quotidiennement voir louis xiv ce qui
était juste important avoir le bon
dresscode un chapeau une épée et si on
n'en possédait pas cela pouvait se louer
l'application dispose de quatre entrées
la visite guidée les trucs et astuces
les zooms sur et les bons plans les deux
fondatrices donnent également leur coup
de coeur sur les lieux qui leur plaisent
car à versailles il n'y a pas que le
château pour télécharger l'application
appy versailles il vous en coûtera 2
euros 69
donc voilà pour ce pour ce sujet est-ce
que pretoria nous faire une petite démo
en direct oui bien les arbres voilà
alors il faut que je me positionne bien
là vous voyez les grands donc notre
volonté a été de fabriquer un produit
simple c'est un audio guide disponible
sur le téléphone de chacun donc il n'ya
pas de 3d il n'y a pas de réalité
augmentée c'est un menu avec quatre
entrées la visite
les 22 salles du château
a star is born louis xiv avec lui l'un
des endroits les plus fascinants au
monde versailles
vous allez pendant une heure vous
transformer en petite souris et vous
payer le luxe de pénétrer dans les
coulisses du palais voilà voilà donc on
a vu effectivement les quatre entrées
même temps avait vu ça dans le reportage
on sent que c'est effectivement un côté
ludique c'est ludique en tout cas c'est
ce soit ludique alors une application
comme celle ci ça coûte combien à mettre
en place par rapport au budget global de
l'application on est parti sur environ
50000 euros qui serait parti sans
différents postes le plus gros poste a
été pour nous la partie une générique
développement technique de l'appli sur
ce sujet là nous n'avions aucune
compétence ni les y animera donc nous
avons vraiment vraiment fait dans ce cas
on contacte les bonnes entreprises mais
je préfère beaucoup d'entreprises sur le
marché dans sas prince oui on a contacté
plusieurs entreprises notamment beaucoup
à l'étranger donc en tunisie en algérie
en inde même est une entreprise aussi
dans les pays de l'est et finalement
nous avons fait le choix d'une
entreprise nantaise
parce que c'était important pour nous
d'avoir une qualité un savoir faire
vraiment reconnue en france d'accord
c'était lors le français le choix de
l'entreprise française je présume que
c'est quand même malgré tout plus chère
parmi ces malgré tout plus cher mais il
ya un service après vente qui à mon avis
ne décevra pas sur le long terme et
bosser sur le service après vente c'est
sur la créativité qu'est ce qui a fait
aussi la différence on la créativité
également oui le service après vente est
très important mais on n'est pas lâcher
dans la nature voilà nous nous sommes
pas technique et on peut quand même
compter sur cette entreprise pour la
suite quand vous dites un surcoût plus
important quand on fait appel un
développeur français sait combien en
plus 20 % 10 % non beaucoup plus j'irai
presque le du simple au double du simple
au double du simple au double c'est
assez troublant d'ailleurs parce que
démarrage voilà on nous propose des
choses on serait tentés d'aller vers une
solution moins chère mais finalement on
avait voilà on a fait quelque chose de
ses riffs furent n'est sûr pour l'avenir
et nos utilisateurs trou ne seront pas
déçus donc les 50000 euros de budget on
a compris le plus la plus grosse part
pris par le développement de cette
application par une société française à
noter quels sont les autres postes alors
qu'il est donc on a eu le
l'enregistrement du comédien qui est une
part importante
du développement économique les visuels
que l'on a acheté on a beaucoup
travaillé sur les visuels de la rmn la
réunion des musées nationaux donc ça
c'est assez cher mais c'est moi là on a
des visuels de qualité c'est important
pour nous et aussi la créativité
graphique de
l'application et la traduction puisque
votre application est à la fois en
français et en anglais oui ça c'est
important quand on ya goûté les
visiteurs du château de versailles
comment s'est fait le financement est ce
que c'est un financement qu'il est
purement fonds propres ou est-ce qu'on
peut bénéficier de dead particulière
qu'on se lance alors nous on est parti
vraiment sur un principe de base
d'autofinancement donc c'est des fonds
propres que l'eia amis et que j'ai tenus
hier personnellement l'idée c'était
vraiment voilà dans un premier temps de
s'autofinancer et en fonction ensuite
des retombées des retours là on pourra
réinvestir dans d'autres projets et
s'autofinancer de cette manne et donc sa
veuve qui a pas possibilité d'obtenir
des aides particulières notamment de la
réunion des musées nationaux ou d'une
même du château de versailles que vous
versez a dit effectué pour vous aider
non non pas vraiment
l'application est payante elle coûte 2
euros 69 alors pourquoi ce choix du
payant on peut se dire que quand on fait
le choix du gratuit on n'attire plus
plus de monde oui c'est vrai il volonté
qualitatif peut-être oui c'est vrai que
les consommateurs ont l'habitude de
télécharger des applications gratuites
nous on a fait le pari du payant parce
que on a un contenu exclusif il est il
n'est disponible donné par ailleurs et
il est de qualité on a vraiment cherché
mon ami de notre nez dans l'est dans les
bouquins on est allés visiter avec des
visites thématiques avec des des guides
officiels du château visiter
le château pour fournir un contenu de
qualité et ont estimé que ce contenu
devait être payant et donc est ce qu'il
y aura de la publicité sur cette
application non pas du tout non non ça
va pas être inondée non alors c'est pas
du tout bio chez les chiens
voilà qui est de 69 qui est pas cher par
rapport à d'autres applications qui
existe déjà dans des musées qui sont
plutôt aux alentours de 4 voire 5 euros
dont on se positionne à un prix qui
paraît vraiment très correct par rapport
au contenu de qualité une heure et demie
de discours des visuels qui nous
projette à l'époque de louis xiv il y en
a pourtant approuvé son argent bon ça
c'est l'application qui vient d'être
relancé comment vous voyez l'avenir
comment vous êtes d'abord amortir ce se
produit alors les retombées pour ce
produit sont de deux sortes on va dire
que ce produit c'est vraiment une
vitrine pour nous c'est important il
montre notre savoir-faire notre ton
décalé notre humour et la façon dont on
raconte les histoires et donc il nous
permet de créer des partenariats d'avoir
des retombées presse d'être sollicité
par divers acteurs qu'on ne connaissait
pas au départ donc ça c'est le premier
axe est le deuxième point
c'est que
on va pouvoir
dans les deux ans on va dire capter 10 %
des 6 millions de visiteurs annuels du
château de versailles que vous avez
estimé 10% voilà dans les 2 ans et 1 c
en plein essor mais ça démarre doucement
sur les applications muséal payante donc
là une api versailles europe d'autres
api voilà exactement en fonction des
retours aidés voilà des opportunités
aussi qui s'ouvriront à nous voilà il
n'y a pas de plans établis ont saisi les
opportunités y en a beaucoup qui arrive
en ce moment mais parce que je les dis
c'est assez précurseur il ya cinquante
et une application muséal en france
c'est très peu donc le marché est très
ouvert et à la fois pas forcément bien
connu oui tout est fait en fait c'est
vrai que il ya peu finalement d'acteurs
sur le marché et les acteurs qui sont
présents sont finalement dans un moule
identique et à petit versailles c'est
vraiment l'électron libre qui vient
jouer le perturbateur dans tous dans
tous hachémite et du coup quel est votre
cible en plus tôt les jeunes je présume
oui les jeunes sont notre coeur de cible
vraiment parce que ils sont sur leurs
tablettes smartphones etc ils vont
vraiment apprendre l'histoire de
versailles en s'amusant ça va les
intéresser et puis comme ce sont deux
forts prescripteurs ils vont aussi en
parler autour d'eux à leur communauté à
leur famille et ça élargit forcément la
cible après on a d'autres cibles aussi
ça vraiment l'application peut être
intéressante pour tout le monde pour
tous les publics de 7 à 77 ans parce
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde à un
smartphone et les publics éloignés aussi
peuvent être une cible intéressante ceux
qui ne peuvent pas se déplacer au
château de versailles eh bien ils
téléchargent l'appli sur leur store et
ils sont confortablement installés dans
leur canapé et peuvent se payer une
visite virtuelle du château de
versailles et ça c'est inédit c'est une
première et avec le temps pourquoi ping
c'est un rapport avec un avec le tube du
moment c'était décidé bien davantage
d'essence que là aussi on était prêts
que combien de temps justement de
préparation en tout appartement vous
avez une idée appartement vous avez
sorti la 9éme wajdi rénale comment un
bébé
ça c'est une très très belle conclut
merci a vous d en tout cas d'être venu
sur le plateau de file echo nous allons
poursuivre cette émission avec le
dossier de la semaine
un marché qui a le vent en poupe les
vélos électriques alors d'un côté des
entreprises qui sont intéressés pour en
louer pour en proposer à leurs salariés
de l'autre des boutiques qui se
spécialise dans ce domaine il faut dire
qu'en france les ventes de vélos
électriques ont plus que doublé en
quatre ans une à deux fois par semaine
evelyne de verre laisse sa voiture à la
maison c'est à vélo qu'elle effectue les
quelques kilomètres qui séparent son
domicile de son travail un vélo
électrique qui lui permet d'allier
moment de détente et gestes pour la
planète sans les désagréments du vélo
traditionnel
effectivement on peut faire 7 à 10
kilomètres voire plus sans vraiment être
fatigué ou en tout cas être froissés on
y voit des vêtements etc c'est
relativement facile enfin justement
enfin on est très assistée donc ça nous
permet effectivement de les mettre dans
toutes les tenues de béraut fascinante 4
ce vélo lui ai mis à disposition par sa
société une initiative qui se développe
de plus en plus dans le monde de
l'entreprise un moyen de répondre aux
exigences gouvernementales de
responsabilité sociétale des entreprises
mais surtout un service à destination
des salariés pour contrer les problèmes
liés à la mise en place et l'entretien
d'un tel parc le directeur du site a
fait appel à une société spécialisée
colibri n'a vraiment là une offre clé en
main les vélos sont préparés entretenu
éventuellement remplacer dans le pire
des cas par colibri
colibri nous fournit également le
logiciel dead à la réservation coup 6000
euros par an la société à l'origine de
ce nouveau service a été créé au début
de l'année des spécialistes du monde du
vélo et de l'entreprise se sont associés
pour créer colibri c'est qu'on n'a pas
même de pollution de transport de stress
passer une heure dans un bus bondé c'est
pas c'est pas génial pour la qualité de
vie au travail donc c'est quelque chose
qui tourne c'est une réflexion qui
tourne dans les entreprises y puiser là
un certain temps et beaucoup avaient
regardé le vélo électrique mais c'était
dit on veut pas que les premiers
questions d'innovation on n'a pas
forcément envie d'investir et surtout on
sera pas le réparer les maintenir pour
les maintenir pierre moulin l'un des
associés passe deux fois par mois
vérifier le matériel il se déplace
également en cas de problème ce gérant
d'un magasin de vélo s'est spécialisée
depuis deux ans dans les vélos
électriques qui face à une demande de
plus en plus forte en 2013 cinquante six
mille six cents vélos à assistance
électrique se sont vendues en france
quatre fois moins qu'aux pays bas mais
ce chiffre est en hausse constante pour
cette offre spécifique aux entreprises
et pierre moulin a choisi un vélo adapté
c'est un modèle tout en aluminium donc à
assistance électrique avec quelques
spécificités un cardan donc pas de
chaîne ce qui avait tout déraillement et
de prendre de grèce donc comme c'est des
vélos qui sont peu d'entreprises on peut
pas salir ils sont réglables pour tous
types d'utilisations qu'avec une potence
réglable en hauteur et en inclinaison
pareil pour la selle autres services un
logiciel de réservation à installer sur
l'intranet des affiches pour communiquer
sur ce service et des vidéos sur la
sécurité routière pour former les
salariés
l'entreprise nous ces vélos français par
tranches de 5 pour le moment leurs
clients des entreprises de 100 à 200
salariés ont opté pour des parcs de cinq
à quinze vélos pour un coût de 5 euros
par jour et par vélo
l'entreprise s'est implantée sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et de saclay pour être au plus près des
sociétés un troisième pôle pourrait voir
le jour à massy mais colibri n'est pas
la seule société à s'être positionné sur
ce marché dans la vallée de chevreuse on
compte déjà un concurrent néo velec son
fondateur thierry ordinn cet ancien
ingénieur d'un grand groupe aéronautique
travailler sur les moteurs d'avion
l'année dernière il a décidé de quitter
le salariat pour l'entrepreneuriat ça
faisait déjà quelques années que me
trottait dans la tête la création
d'entreprise voilà j'avais envie j'avais
envie de me lancer mais je ne savais pas
quoi et puis il ya deux ans j'ai
découvert le vélo à assistance
électrique et j'ai une formation de base
en mécanique c'est l'ingénieur
mécanicien et j'ai trouvé simplement
génial thierry ordinn a lancé l'activité
commerciale il y à un mois il propose à
la vente et à la location des vélos à
assistance électrique uniquement deux
marques européennes mais ici plusieurs
modèles sont disponibles
vtt vtc vélos pliants et triporteurs et
tous les publics sont visés entreprises
mais aussi collectivités et particuliers
et au valais crée de la vente et ou de
la location est tout et panache à bhl et
le concept est basé sur vraiment les
attentes du client j'ai une culture
d'entreprise et de service après vente
et support clients assez forte et l'idée
est scellé concept que j'ai développé
puisque j'en ai différents qui sont qui
sont toujours basés sur la flexibilité
donc on peut mettre un vélo trois vélos
50 vélos en place on peut panacher de la
vente et de la location on peut panacher
les types de vélos cet entrepreneur
propose également des accessoires de
l'antivol aux décorations de casques et
des animations en entreprise son
concurrent et une position différente un
service exclusivement pour les
professionnels la mise à disposition
d'un logiciel de réservation et un vélo
unique nous c'est un vélo standard à
qu'on a vraiment taillé pour ça que j'ai
l'impression qu'ils bouffent le
catalogue dit quel type de vélo vous
voulez donc je pense qu'il y aura des
problèmes déjà des preuves à faire
décider des entreprises sur un vélo
qu'on a choisi des femmes en bien
les deux sociétés pense malgré tout il
ya de la place pour tout le monde et que
l'offre aux entreprises se développera
encore davantage au fil du temps face à
l'engouement des salariés le dernier
client date donnée au velez qu'est
justement le salarié d'un grand groupe
qui souhaite aller travailler à vélo
tirer ordinn vient lui livrer un antivol
ce que j'ai cherché céder quelque chose
pour m'aider à monter la dépense parce
qu'il peut faire du vélo c'est le
placent son problème mais ce qui
m'inquiétait sa perle est alimentée et
ne pas arriver à complètement survolée
néo velec et colibri espère tous deux
embauches et des techniciens d'ici la
fin de l'année
avant de se quitter on passe à l'agenda
de rendez vous à noter cela se passe à
la cité des métiers de trappes le mardi
13 mai première conférence à 10 heures
consacrées la fonction publique
territoriale pour tout savoir de ses
métiers et des opportunités d'emploi et
puis deuxième rencontre toujours le 13
mai cette fois 10h30 un thème très
actuel et qui va forcément intéressés
l'e-réputation une rencontre et servait
aussi bien aux entrepreneurs qu'aux
salariés afin d'apprendre à créer son
profil sur les réseaux sociaux sociaux
par an et surtout à le gérer ce numéro
de fil des coûts est terminé merci de
votre attention la semaine prochaine
vous retrouverez clair combien il sera
notamment question des mini-entreprises
bonne semaine